You're still here, fantastic.
I know you want to get to the juicy
bits, but I need to bother your once
again with a bunch of general advice,
so you don't shoot yourself in the foot.
Not all tools are created equal, and
like you learned in the quiz,
not all optimizations are worth doing.
Let's go through a few common
scenarios that set you up for failure.
Chances are you probably can't.
And even if you can,
it won't be worth it.
To give you a web dev example, hundreds
of engineering years went into tiny js
libraries like jQuery,
including some of my time actually.
And yet, countless developers have
tried to replicate it with a 90%
similar feature set,
only to fail hard, again and again.
Even popular clones like Zepto, couldn't
keep up when they realized that jQuery
fixed a lot more cross-browser
maintenance than people thought.
Even in modern browsers.
Now we're talking idealistic
versus pragmatic.
Yes, that 20% speed
increase will be ideal.
But sticking to a tool that is
well supported by the community,
is pragmatic.
Gulp might be a little slower
than someone else's new tool.
But you'll find answers for your
questions on stack overflow, plugins for
virtually anything and
can rest assured, that the tool is
going to be maintained by its creators.
Don't just trust your instincts, but
consider the long-term value for
your project.
So, it's neatly contained.
All in package, huh?
Well, be careful with those.
If a tool promises to do it all, and
stays away from offering any sort of
connection points, say,
in API or modules, run.
No, seriously.
Life is too short to buy into
an ecosystem that you can't escape from,
especially if the success
of your site depends on it.
And finally, you should be careful with
any micro optimizations that are just
not worth it.
If you are doing an optimization of your
work flow that takes, say four hours,
and cuts a second away from a task
you perform once during the day,
you need to do it for
40 years to justify the investment.
And in 40 years, you could be sitting
in an intergalactic flying car,
exploring the outer
realms of space instead.